hey guys welcome back to the Spates wad
podcast it is the final dance in France
review gez Lads I I felt all sorts of
emotions after today's game um I guess
that's the beauty of the sport U we can
be so invested into it but man I've been
just thinking about all sorts of um
situations that came out of that game
and sort of reliving at all but um
obviously South Africa um what a side
they are they'll be absolutely pumped
after there I love hearing kisi speak
after the game um they've done it
incredibly tough three one-point
victories um in the playoff games that's
an incredible stat and the first team to
ever win four Rugby World Cups that's
also um such an unbelievable stat as
well lots to dissect in this one um
couple of games there as well of course
we're joined by the last time wh by sule
from suly talk Sport and the legend
Jacob the snob Atkins um Jacob I'll
start with you as a neutral and the only
one to pick the winner what' you make of
the game
mate um yeah well we're kind of
digesting it in real time here aren't we
Lads we normally obviously have a couple
of days to go over the games have a
thing come up with some analysis and
we're kind of uh just reacting to what
we've just seen recording the the day of
the game
um I guess reacting as a neutral it
wasn't the kind of game we wanted I
think that was obviously dictated by the
conditions um in terms of the game was
really Scrappy really high error count
um and it basically became a game
of managing in those errors as opposed
to yeah you know trying to make huge
plays happen we obviously saw a few one
of them got choked off I'm sure you'll
you'll go uh you'll go over that in
detail you Lads but um I just I
mentioned it on the preview last week I
just think the South Africa team is set
up to win these ugly games um they the
best in the world at it they have been
for a long time um and they have that
sort of like emotional maturity and
resilience that R's built in that group
that things don't really seem to phase
them I thought you know the moment we
saw it was raining quite heavily in
Paris before kickoff we were concerned
it might be a rough day for the All
Blacks um and they struggled in a few
areas that we thought they might they
struggled under the high ballum in the
backfield South Africa basically put
England's game plan from last week onto
them
um and uh you know similar style to how
how they ended up beating France um I
just think as well like the South Africa
team they're so battle hardened they've
had so many of these games like you
alluded to just there in the in your
buildup gym like they had a close game
against England they had a very very
similar game to this against France I
would say conditions didn't dictate as
much but the style that they played the
game in and the way the game played out
was very similar to their their
quarterfinal against France they
obviously had that tough game in the
group stage against Ireland and Scotland
they came out of a really really tough
group and I just think that maybe came
through the way the game panned out yeah
yeah it's it's a shame that things
things like the conditions have such a
big impact on a final you want to see
the two teams both offering their best
and I just felt New Zealand were kind of
playing with well one hand tied behind
their back and then the red card two
hands tied behind their back at times
and they did a great job to push it as
close as they did and if they'd won it I
think it would have been one of the
great World Cup upsets to win those
circumstances but uh just one step too
far I think too too many obstacles to
overcome in that last game yeah mate
would have been such an
incredible um Victory if they could have
won and like so many things they were so
close such small margins in these big
games like like we spoke about um
throughout the whole um preview show
that these games often come down to um
one or two moments and you can look back
on so many of them and think what if or
how could they but obviously um you
mentioned South Africa and their ability
to that emotional maturity and um their
ability to win these um such close games
consistently like three in a row
onepoint victories don't think that will
ever happen again at a Rugby World Cup
like um just the grit and the the
passion they show for for their country
like you say like they always shout out
like for their country that they do love
it um but geez it was hard break so
obviously we'll get to you suley you're
the you're the emotion of New Zealand
you've you've been writing this journey
all day how are you feeling mate mate it
was emotional wasn't it like right from
the anthems you could tell that this
game was special um just those scenes of
like kisi in the tunnel singing Village
songs like it's just like I had
goosebumps man and then the players walk
out the anthems like I've never seen so
much passion from both sides and then
the hucker of course the French managed
to sneaker national anthem in between as
well so full credit to them you know
they've been in formed all tournament
and they really made it count on the
biggest stage but yeah what a roller
coaster of a game like obviously Sam
Kane you're heartbroken for him there
were moments there where you just like
you said little bounces of the ball Arty
running onto that chip kick from Jordy
like will you ever get closer to scoring
a try there were moments there but I
guess the overall disappointment and
frustration and I guess we'll talk about
it but it was just not the game I think
that we deserved and that it was built
up to be you've got these two proud
rugby Nations both chasing four all week
there were Throwbacks to 95 and all this
type of stuff and I just think what we
were dished up wasn't the spectacle that
we'd all hoped we were it's like I feel
like we lost that game but I don't know
if we lost to a better team so to say I
just feel like both teams were not
really given the opportunity to control
the narrative at times and I feel like
that's going to be the main talking
point from this and I hate that we have
excuses as to why we lost when it should
just be a team winning and South Africa
100% deserve it but of course fans here
are just going to blame everything else
that went on and quite rightfully so in
many circumstances as well so that
almost makes it even sadder is like you
can't tip your hat and just be like man
we were completely outplayed there
because there were so many circumstances
and other sub narratives in the game
that led to the outcome yeah I remember
saying in the preview show that I was
really hoping for a non-controversial um
Victory because um then we wouldn't have
all this debate and um we could Clearly
say that one team's was clearly the best
but um that definitely wasn't the case
um there's lots of controversy in it um
but I you got to hand it to South Africa
the way they played to those conditions
like like snake said they kicked really
well they knew the conditions weren't
suited for playing they backed their
defense and they defended bloody well
like step DET toy um 28 tackles 28 of
the biggest collisions I think I've ever
seen and like you you said it before CLI
around Jordy Barrett um rib cage man he
was just flying into Paul Jordy who we
rely a lot on game line and a lot of
those carries he was getting game line
until he ran into him but um South
Africa's defense and um just the
pressure game I think they they beat us
at that and um the I love how the All
Blacks were still playing like in the
conditions they still gave the ball air
they're still playing the space and they
found it a couple of times and um
obviously the probably one of the
greatest tries in Rugby World Cup
history with the Richie Mo show and go
um to only be wiped um that was a that
was a huge moment in the game but it was
incredible
stuff yeah I mean like listening to how
we're sort of reviewing the game now
it's making me realize even more like
it's actually outrageous that the All
Blacks got it to a onepoint game there
you think like South Africa played
really well I I totally they didn't just
kick a lot like they kicked very very
well they were really really accurate
with their kicks that their their
kicking execution was much better than
new zealands as well as um actually the
fact that they looked to kick more the
defense was awesome and New Zealand
played was 65 well no because there was
yellow cards as well so New Zealand
played 65 minutes with basically 14 men
M everything stacked against him to to
get it to a one-point game
is outrageous in all honesty like the
more and more I think about it yeah and
the other thing that we we spoke about
earlier in the tournament was South
Africa's goal kicking obviously when
they played Ireland um leok was kicking
he missed a few cost them the game um
obviously paard hasn't missed a kick
this Rugby World Cup well that's a stat
New Zealand had a couple of chances
tough kicks obviously one from the
sideline one from 50 m on the 15 like
not not real kickable easy kicks but um
just to think if one of those went over
um could have been a different story you
never really know um but yeah the
importance of kicking like you said
snake and you're the kicking Guru too so
you would have known they come going
over as soon as they left the bo
although to be fair a couple of Po's
early ones were just squeak one off the
post and front
too
yeah but sure yeah another another thing
with um South Africa is um obviously
their Skipper kisi like what an
incredible man that guy is first guy to
ever lift the Trophy twice um you hear
him speak after a game and you've just
got to love the guy like he is
incredible how he will um address an
afterm match speech um you talk about
him singing geez I love watching him
sing the national anthem he gets his
head right back mouth wide wi open and
just goes for it and um just the passion
that he has and you can see he's got all
the boys around him and they've got a
really good leadership group there so um
he's got to be one of the greatest
captains ever what do you reckon sirle
yeah I 100% agree I can't speak highly
enough of them like in World sport I
reckon he's got to be right up there in
terms of history of the best leaders
just given like everything that goes on
in South Africa we all know that it's a
pretty divided nation at times but
whoever you speak to over the speak so
highly of kisi like you'd have to think
politics if he wanted to post rugby like
he's someone that you could imagine that
their country would literally vote for
just hearing the passion the way he
speaks how inclusive he is of everyone
and yeah your heartbroken that we lost
but I think we said it the other week
like if New Zealand weren't to win it I
wanted South Africa just for kisi like
just cuz I like him I don't have an
emotional attachment to any of the other
players but I like seeing him succeed
because when you hear guys like Ary Sam
Kane all that speak about him he's just
so genuine you can't not like the guy so
I'm happy for him and don't get me wrong
with what I said before South Africa did
deserve it like they executed a game
plan beautifully those little cross
kicks they were putting in perfectly
like they identified with umbrella and
on D they found space there like they
executed a game plan perfectly it was
more meaning more The Narrative than
that but I'm stoked for kisi to to get
that one and be the first to four the
first guy to lift it back to back
because I think he's a figure that will
remember in World sport a long time post
his
retirement your spot on and um I
remember you actually saying I think it
must have been the very first um preview
show when we tried to predict our play
of the tournament and you said oh how
good of a story would it be kissi
remembering that he's coming back from a
ACL injury U he he shouldn't be at this
world cup most people wouldn't even um
you know most people it's N9 months I'm
not sure how he's managed to do that in
sort of three or four but um incredible
effort to get back out there and to Sam
lift that Trophy and speak about what it
means for South Africa obviously here in
New Zealand we love our rugby and we're
very passionate about it but it it's a
different ball game over there in South
Africa you don't have to watch that
Invictus movie one of the great movies
to um you would have watched that a few
times snake um to realize go to yeah I
think it's his white noise while he goes
to bed isn't it that's his go to
met Damon with one of the great
performances at sex
or8 but it does mean so much to them eh
yeah yeah yeah man they they're built
different I mean London is absolutely
packed with with kiwis and safas
especially the bit of London I live in
so the pubs yesterday were absolutely
awesome over here absolutely Ram every
score one side of the pub would go nuts
and the other side of the pub would go
nuts for the other side um but um you're
right the the The Passion of the South
African fanss comes from a different
place I think the passion of the New
Zealand fans comes from the love of the
actual game the love of like code Rugby
Union um but when the South Africans
celebrate it's about South Africa it's
almost like the the game is kind of
irrelevant what they're actually
celebrating is how much they love South
Africa and the country and you know the
kiwis are very much like lowkey might
have an all blacks cap or a black Jersey
but it's whereas there like flags hats
[__] horns all that stuff in the pub
so it's it's a completely different
level of um like sort of passion that
they have when they watch this team play
isn't it spot on and and I guess the big
thing the big talking point at the
moment from everyone um is the
refereeing performance which is which is
a shame and it was always thing we
mentioned at the start of the reviews at
the start of the tournament that we're
hope hoping it wasn't going to be and
the Rifts could stay out of the
Limelight but obviously they they hit
the Limelight pretty hard in this one um
but it's just so hard in such in these
tight games um the way the game is um
the way the rules are in the game it
just makes it incredibly hard for a
referee to do a job without getting
involved and I guess the biggest thing
for me um it's been my pit hate for a
while is the involvement of the T TMO
and um I can I can live with decisions
not getting right like some of those
decisions 50/50 or maybe
7525 Wayne bars might have got wrong but
In the Heat of the Moment the speed of
the play it's very hard to get all those
right and you can live with those things
I hate is missing magic moments and like
that Richie moonga uh try uh setup try
for Aaron Smith that can't be pulled
back I think we we lose we lose a
massive part of the game if we're going
to start bringing those back um for me
my suggestion to World rugby will be
that the referee only sends it up to the
TMO if he wants to check a tri being
scored or if he wants to check Foul Play
everything else if you get away with
something you get away with something
and we're going to as fans we're just
going to have to accept there's going to
be some wrong decisions but for me it's
so much better than a Tamo checking
everything and losing so much of the
momentum of the game and like new people
watching that game you you'll be
thinking what the heck has he gone back
there for like that South African
knocked his hand at the Rock so how have
they lost the try like it's just like
it's it seems crazy like award the tries
make it flying I remember like and
that's not just a bias thing either
because I remember even that uh South
Africa All Blacks game before the World
Cup where um Moody the center scored
that incredible TR tooking and beat a
few Defenders and then they go all the
way back to check a minor offside and
like at the time I remember saying we
should never um call back those tries
they've got to be awarded we've if the
referee suspects something then he can
send it up but um Barnes didn't send up
Sam Kane's Collision he didn't send up
K's Collision that's all come back he
didn't send up any of those tries it was
um yeah it's a Tamo double-checking
everything and and just ruining the flow
of the game for me what's your thoughts
here suley yeah I agree a lot of people
have come out for pretty for Wayne
Barnes and like we were on here last
week saying he's the best man to do the
job and look H I still think he might
well have been it's so hard for him
obvious like yeah well he's got people
in his ear nonstop telling him stuff
whether it's players whether it's the
TMO who was in his ear a lot and by the
end of the game you could tell Wayne and
had enough like he just started
disregarding it and I wish he kind of
did a bit earlier but you can't blame
him but like you said you can live with
human error like that penalty where he
said to after he watched the replay
sorry mate I got that wrong it results
in three points and many people now are
saying that that cost us the game but I
feel way better about that decision than
some of the other ones that got sent up
from from upstairs because we had
opportunities to get those penalties
back what you can't get back is players
going to the Bur or tries disallowed and
things like that like the saddest thing
for me around this TMO stuff is when you
see a try get scored now and you react
with emotion you're so pumped up your
group chats everything go off man what a
play from Richie Mo and then it just
gets called back it's like you can't
celebrate these moments now until the
ball is on the tea and by then it's it's
more a feeling of relief that you've
scored you lose that like that passion
with all your mates that you're at a
game you're like wow what a moment and
then it's bought back and you're crushed
so when that when bod scored I was
sitting there just being like n n n not
until it not until it gets awarded yeah
I was just like they're going to bring
this back and that's not what the game's
all about like imagine like you said if
you're sitting there with your kids or
whatever and you're trying to get them
into the game and how do you explain
these decisions let alone they get it
and they're fizzed up they want to see
tries and then they get disallowed it's
just I'm the TMO I think they can only
act on something if it happens in that
phase so as soon as there's a breakdown
they can't then come back to an error
that was prior to that so it has to be
in the phase leading to a try I think
that's what it should be rugby league
does something very similar I also think
it would be great if we just had the TMO
like you said just for tries but then
each team gets a captain's challenge so
if a player's not happy with a shot they
think that they've been taken high no
arms shoulder to the Head they can go to
their captain and be like mate I just
got smoked there can you use the
captain's challenge let's review that
and then if they get it wrong then they
live by that I think that might actually
help as well because at the moment
there's they're intervening for knock on
and things like that from three phases
ago and it's just not good for the game
like you you start to zone out a bit
yeah you're right like my kids were
watching the game with me and they're
still trying to work out how Aaron
Smith's tries didn't count on the
scoreboard like um if you do
a it's a try like that should be a legit
rule if there's a Goosey into a dummy
you can't overrall that because that is
just poetry yeah and I guess one thing
we didn't sort of preview was um
obviously the refereeing group all
English snaky so they've obviously been
over in the English premiership for the
last 10 years refering the English
premiership which um for kiwi fans who
don't watch the English premiership it
is refereed a lot more intensely than
Super Rugby the tamamo's in a lot more
um I feel like head cisions are refereed
a lot more harshly than they are um in
Super Rugby but I'm hearing Foster talk
after the game he knew that they had
these guys in the Irish Series so that
they're aware of it but I think a lot of
the public weren't aware of it hence why
um everyone's pretty shocked but what's
your thoughts on that yeah obviously
Jimmy you you played in both
competitions So you you're probably in a
in a good place to feel the differences
I've never played in in the southern
hemisphere but they definitely they
definitely go with a much finer comb
through everything and it's the norm to
see anything flagged up you know the
amount of time we'll be watching a game
in a pub and you'll just hear people in
the back going check check check check
check check which is what the TMO says
when he's seen something that he wants
to speak to ref for a bit reab about
because it's just it's such an accepted
part of the game in the Premiership
you'll just be watching it and you'll
hear check check and you just think
right okay whatever happens to the next
four phases might not matter because
they're going to go back to something
six or seven phases ago and I I really
empathize with what you said at the
start Jimmy because there there has to
be some kind of guidelines on where it
ends because where do you draw the line
like do we go do we go like oh [__]
actually South Africa knocked the ball
in in the third minute Lads you got to
get back out on the field like we got to
go start again like we're starting the
game from minute three again like where
do you where do you draw the line on
picking up mistakes and you also then
put your sit yourself in that situation
where you're saying okay we picked up
that knock on we have to go back for
that well if that's the case then you
have to get every knock on in the game
and you have to like I said you have to
go back and we have to replay from every
single knock on in the game whereas if
you treat it like what Jimmy's been
saying the whole time we've been
recording this podcast if you accept
that there's 30 errors throughout a game
that can go against either side and TMO
can only intervene for for set
parameters within certain situations you
know for example in the Premier League V
only comes in for penalty reviews and
for goal reviews that's it and even then
you know it's a system where it's not
great fans don't really like it for the
exact reason that surley just said
because you score a goal and straight
away everyone's like have they checked
it have they checked it if they checked
it so that's by no means perfect either
um but I definitely think there needs to
be harder or harer guidelines on where
they can intervene in the play and how
retrospective the decision can be
because you're opening yourself up to so
much criticism if you're saying we're
reviewing everything because then you
could just you know all blacks fans
could just sit there all game and just
find knock on and be like okay well the
game only started in minute five yeah oh
it's the last thing we just you just
lose the flow we need to get the flow
back and into the game um and to me the
best way to do that is to take out as
much of the TMO as possible go back even
if it was old school like um one referee
in the middle just doing everything I
don't know but um yeah I that's my
thoughts anyway I guess the other thing
um around the I guess the abuse of the
referee is I guess the importance of
commentators and people having their say
especially the people um in the know um
sharing their thoughts and if if if
you're going to abuse a referee or
criticize the game well then that's what
these people are watching and they are
going to share that in the messes on
their social media so I just think that
that was something that really stood out
to me during halim and after the game
around some of the the I guess negative
media around it um what what's your
thoughts there sirly yeah it's hard
isn't it because we as people that watch
a lot of rugby can easily make up our
minds but when you have like family
members relatives and stuff who don't
watch a lot of footy and they just tune
in for these big games they certainly
talking to them after they're just
repeating exactly what they've heard
right and like that's natural for
something that you don't know a lot
about people do it all the time in
everyday life you see it on social media
24/7 but it has a massive play in The
Narrative that's then set post the game
so I'm all for seeing like emotion and
things like that particularly and great
moments like that Tri bod scored at the
World Cup like the go Boden like that
iconic commentary I'm all for that but
when it's going in and piling in on
someone I'm not all for that as well
because you then start a dog pile on so
I see both sides where like you want
people to be authentic and say what they
would say normally but yeah you do have
to remember that you're in a position of
power and influence there so you just
got to pick your words wisely well
that's something you do very well both
of you so selling the game very well on
this podcast
everyone who's doing it but I guess
overall from that game I'm super proud
of that All Black's effort to to go as
close as they did with 14 men for as
long as they did and I guess their whole
tournament coming back from the loss
against France a tough start and then
getting all the way to the to the final
um very proud of of our men and black so
but we'll get to the next game we we we
won't be as detailed on this one but
England and Argentina um watching it
couldn't help but I think this was
clearly not the third and fourth best
team at the Rugby World Cup um there's
some fairly average rugby it sort of
felt like seventh fifth eightth sort of
setup but um England got the job done
another very close Victory what do you
make of it
snake uh yeah it was a game that
happened I best way to sum it up is we
were talking on our group chat and uh
when Argentina had a goal to level it we
were all just saying like oh please miss
this so it doesn't go to extra time
please we just we can't watch you know
an extended period of this 30 more
minutes of this no I think it was two
teams that were physically dust really
from the World Cup probably emotionally
dust like we mentioned after tough
semi-final losses for both of them in
different ways obviously England tough
semi-final loss the way they lost
Argentina tough to get pumped for 80
minutes um but also two teams who for me
are probably am I gonna be this harsh
probably the worst
coached least tactically Advanced teams
in the comp would we say of of the big
the bigger sides who are in the mix in
The Knockout stages so there wasn't a
lot to really get your teeth stuck into
was it it was basically a bit of a
scramble scramble Fest pretty average
attack on both sides pretty average
defense on both sides the collisions
were good there was some good set P
stuff but nothing that I I really want
to talk about in great detail I mean the
the thing for me as I obviously said in
the preview show before the result
didn't matter to me I didn't care if
england finished third or fourth in this
world cup like I said like Jimmy just
said for me they're probably still in
that seventh eth slot in the world
rankings and that's a better reflection
of where we're at I just wanted to see a
performance that showed
me something that we could get behind
for our next campaign you know something
the for the Six Nations or Autumn series
or whatever it is that we go into next I
don't know the international calendar um
but something that we could be like okay
that's where that's base camp now the
team can grow from there and we just
didn't see that at all did we the the
attack was
non-existent there's no creativity
there's no room for individ it's so
rigid there's no room for individual
players to move and flow without the
within within the shape that they have
there's no opportunity for guys to
really work off the ball like we've
spoken about how how much we enjoy
seeing that you spoke about seeing it
live at the All Blacks game certainly
watching guys manipulate the space to
work manipulate the shape sorry to work
for them working off the ball
transitioning between different patterns
and we just don't see any of that from
England at all it's very very rigid it's
very very structured but it's not even
executed well if you're going to be
rigid and structured like you have to be
on it with your execution and it has to
be like detail has to be unbelievable
and they're just they're just not there
as a group at the moment and I think
I've made it very clear that I don't
necessarily think that the program is
being run by the right people at the
moment I didn't think that when they
first came in I thought the selection
was a strange one to replace Eddie Jones
um uh with borwick it felt to me like a
um like a trend pick because he'd won
the premiership with Leicester the
season before and had turned them around
you guys don't want Su Prem much
Leicester obviously a big uh historic
Club they were having a really poor
patch they nearly got relegated one year
he came in three seasons later they won
the premiership really great turnaround
Arc for the club
but that was very much a guy coming in
and rebuilding a club it wasn't
necessarily a guy being the most
technically and tactically advanced
coach and I think that is what you need
at International level it's not the same
as a club system I mean I don't have any
coaching experience Jim you might be
able to speak better on this but I think
International Rugby coaching is a very
very different Prospect to Club rugby
coaching where you're building a team
and a squad for a competition week in
week out um and I just don't think
they've got the right guys in the right
seat and I believe that England have the
players um and the player pull so the
the group of players outside the squad
to be competitive I do still think we've
got one of the best talented groups of
players in the world um but I just think
it starts from the top and I don't see
this team progressing unless they make
changes at the top for me I'd love to be
proved wrong and I'd love them to go on
a transition through the next four years
and become dominant and World beating
but I don't see where where that comes
from mate it's hard to believe you're
talking about the third best team in the
world right now they've just won the
bronze medal the Rugby World
cff absolutely slating
them but it's true like I found that
game hard to watch because I felt like
England had Argentina on the ropes but
they just had zero Killer Instinct they
just could not for some reason um stick
the knife and they kept going for the
three points when I felt like they were
clearly all on top of them um even in
phas shape they' have advantage and
they'd grubber it into touch instead of
playing a shape down the edge where they
could maybe get their backs involved um
they went because Argentina I spoke
about Argentina's Edge day I felt like
it was it's not strong and they went
there a couple of times they scored when
Earl went through um but they didn't go
there much much more and um that was the
biggest frustration for me I obviously
had Harry uh Henry andal on my um
fantasy team as Captain so I was
watching this game hoping they were
going to get um the ball to the edge had
two touches kick them both and absolute
nightmare for my fantasy team cost me
the tournament but um I guess it's my
fault for captaining an English Winger
isn't it what do you make of it sirle
yeah pretty much what snaky said I when
he mentioned the word manipulation
before that's all I had written down for
this game is when I sit down and watch a
game between two mutual teams I want to
see an attacking side manipulate
defenses and just expose weaknesses and
you know you want to see that battle
between 80 minutes of teams trying to
work each other out but it just wasn't
that at all was it really like it was
just kind of bash and crash too like
solid passionate Ford packs going at it
but man there's so much more in both of
these nations we've seen it from them
before like Argentina came here last
year and bit New Zealand playing a great
brand of football England have done it
so many times as well where like yes
they've always had a great kicking game
and they've always been quite criticized
down here for the way they play but
they've had individuals that they've
allowed Express themselves when you
think of like the the great English
players throughout the years there's
some amazing outside backs and I still
believe they have the talent to do that
but like snaky said they just kind of
Coach military Styles at the moment and
you hate to say it CU it's harsh but I
think they kind of want to be on that
springbox type of level but they're like
a poor man's version of it at the moment
because they can't execute that style of
play as well and the spring box also
have a bit of R in them which England
could do but they just failed to unleash
it so yeah I'm a bit worried about them
under bwick just because of his
messaging post game and stuff he's
talking like they've now found their way
to play especially after losing to South
Africa like he was stoked with that and
he was like this is the blueprint for
the next four years no one expected us
to be here we almost bet them like this
is how we're going to play and I don't
know if that's the way to do it to
double down on that style of code
because yeah you're not going to beat
the best teams in the world doing that
consistently I don't feel like you're
just hoping to drag them into a ship
fight and and come away with it and
you're not going to be able to do that
for a Whole World
Cup right you'll both make very very
valid points but I guess from a finals
point of view um the the fact is that um
this Rugby World Cup still gave us
playoff games where seven of the eight
games came down to to the very last play
so that's a massive Plus for where World
rugby is at um I know a lot of people
have been quite negative about the
tournament now post that final but the
fact is that seven of those eight games
came to the very last play so um that's
an incredible stat I don't think that
will probably happen again um but just
goes to show like if we had these
quarterfinals again starting now like
this week um same games I'm I guarantee
we' have different teams and third and
fourth and different teams in the final
like the teams are just that close um
and the things that swing either way um
the games were just such fine margins
anything on that suly no I just think
like when you talk 2023 World Cup like
you mentioned I think everyone will just
remember those quarterfinals two of them
especially as like iconic games in rugby
and it's again like it's almost a shame
that it won't be remembered for the
final it will be remembered for those
two quarters
um and some great pool games as well
like overall as a competition I think
it's been really good there's obviously
got its flaws but you know Portugal Fiji
you had those story teams that like
people really got behind then you had
France beaing New Zealand first up and
then the results all kind of playing out
how they have Ireland South Africa so we
were treated to some good games
throughout this competition it's just a
shame that it finished kind of on that
note but those quarterfinals man like
that they'll be remembered forever yeah
you're right it's a shame one of those
quarterfinals wasn't the wasn't the
final really it would have been such a
cool way to finish U what has been an
awesome Rugby World Cup so um a couple
of things that come out from last week
obviously um the nominees will play of
the year I'm pretty Keen to get your
guys prediction there so obviously I
think that's tonight even so this is
going to be fresh Player of the Year
nominees Dupont Ary ianeth and Bundy key
who are you going
snake I think the obvious one would be
Theon um I think it's fairly easy what
they've tried it's very clear sorry what
they've tried to do there they've tried
to identify one player from each of the
big four International Teams at this
world cup um I think bndy AR is maybe a
bit of a reach I don't know if you boys
agree with me I think they probably felt
we have to get one Ireland player in
here because Ireland have been the sort
of outstanding team for the last two
years
um but as I've said so often on this
podcast like Ireland are an outstanding
team because they're so well connected
organized and coached they don't
necessarily have the world
beating players that go one for one up
against other teams you know I actually
said when it was one of the games maybe
it was theel New Zealand game I don't
know how many Ireland players I would
pick in a combined 15 but together
they're better than the sum of their
parts um so I I'm not I'm not sold 100%
on the nominations list but I think the
OB VI one is Dupont I can't imagine you
guys are going to disagree with that too
much I mean 's had a fantastic World Cup
um but I think DuPont's the best rugby
play I've ever seen play the game let
alone this year yeah it's it's
interesting like all the comments I'm
reading is that it's all about Arty
maybe I'm because I'm New Zealand heavy
but I'm with you I think it's so hard
not to give it to DuPont I know he
probably hasn't had the World Cup that
um he could have he still played really
well every time he played but he
obviously
um was out for a few weeks with the
fracture um didn't get to plan semis and
finals so obviously people you won't get
to I guess add up those scores as well
but 's had a massive year he's so
consistent he he's a freak um I think
it's out of those two personally
obviously South Africa winning it um do
they lean toward even isabeth there
because of the fact that they won it um
is he the best player has he been the
best player this year he hasn't been for
me but um yeah I'm with you I'd
personally go to Pont or very closey
what about you sirle yeah I think I
agree obviously I love AI so that kind
of puts the blinkers on a little but I
think it would be 6040 in terms of deont
I think like kiwi fans we see so much of
RDA and he's like that leader that just
and that player that everyone loves
you'll never hear anyone say a bad word
about them so I think it's only natural
for us to be like I yeah is unreal but I
think when you factor in DuPont's year
of work and just like if he's not in
that French team it just falls apart in
a way like he is the Maestro that makes
them the best one of the best teams in
the world and if he's not there then
they kind of drop down to that six or
seven range which might be a little
harsh they do have some good depth and
stuff but I just feel like yeah he he's
a wizard so um yeah either of them
deserve it it'll be interesting to see
which way they go but yeah if you said
to me right now who's the best player in
World rugby I'd say jaon yeah fair
enough I'm very hard to argue the other
one is the Breakthrough um I think this
man is clearly what we spoke about him
how much baby will he's got him he still
had it on him in the final man this guy
is incredible man he can create some
stuff Mark T anyone disagree with that
hard to make a case eh for anyone else
and that yeah it's the obvious pick in
it yeah and Coach I'm interested in the
coach because why is r not nominated for
Coach of the Year CU he's not he's not
the South African coach he's South
African director of rugby so he was the
head coach at the last World Cup he
stepped back they brought in a new head
coach and then they brought Razzy back
in as like a cultural and Vibes director
so he actually the the head coach wow I
didn't know that that is that is good I
was wondering I was reading that like
has the assistant been on he must he
must be an absolute wizard yeah because
if you look at you know you know
International Teams do their before
every test match they do the photo the
guy sat in the
middle that who I don't know his name is
the head coach yeah Jack Jax n something
it's interesting though because ja and
russie pick the team like Russ's very
much involved every camera shot it it
Clips to Russy but ja just happens to be
in the shot as well it's it's hard case
but yeah yeah I you could go some
interesting ways with this coach run
because I agree like does the Fijian
coach will Louie not deserve it man like
the the progression in their game as
well has been crazy so it depends how
you want to look at things obviously
South Africa they've just won a World
Cup and they had like the All Blacks
they had a pretty interesting year
coming in like so their form into the
tournament obviously they smoked us at
Twickenham but their rugby Championship
form in that wasn't amazing so it's
going to be hard to overlook him but
that that Fijian coach could be right up
there yeah and don't forget FAL either
like year that Island had 17 wins on the
Trot until that quarterfinal um snake's
already said it like probably not the
best player for player Squad but best
Coach side he believes so like there a
real good case for all of them and even
fzy who's had a hell of a tough year to
be able to get their All Blacks into
that performance into the final um as it
makes a shout but I don't think he'll be
winning it for me it will be either oh
probably any of the other three really
could make a case for all of them so
interesting we'll follow that one
closely lastly to finish my fantasy team
everyone wants to know where I finished
up and this is tough with that last
round but I think everyone had a pretty
shocking round with um there wasn't many
points available um in those last two
games but it ended up dropping two spots
um finished an 11th um disappointing
finish but I think fantasy Rugby's been
one of the real successes of this Rugby
World Cup man lots of lots of messages
um lots of interaction with people
around um watching the games getting up
early to watch their triple Captain play
in a minnow game which just gives you
all that extra interest so rugby
definitely need to double down on that
when they hit Super Rugby this year um
shout out to iddie Jones as my dad who
won the water lead League um hey got a
win congrat he could be the Mi coach of
the W by the sounds
of he might be off to Japan with his old
man or is
he and a special thanks to Mint andies
for supplying um andies for all the
winners of these um Instagram
competitions that I've had going
throughout the year to add a little bit
of Interest as well um no one got bod
Barrett at the 60 something minute mark
it was would have been a tough
prediction but um maybe we'll get
another crossover um competition going
for another another time but appreciate
you two guys for coming on we weekly as
well I'm giving in your insights true
Lads um looking forward to seeing where
your analysis game goes over the next
few years um potentially on the TV or I
know at least the radio for both of you
so your passort and get over here snake
yeah cheers lad I'll see you in what
Australia yes that's
it on the field surely yeah hopefully
the podcast has grow massively by then
we can always be sitting in
the with our mics just live
commentary and reactions but we'll see
where we get to appreciate your time as
always Lads
leg Yeah it's been awesome I've loved it
boys